we've got a theme of sort of hypocrisy
or something much worse than hypocrisy
going here this next video this is ben
and jerry you know these hippie 60s ice
cream people they did an absolutely
debacle i mean a true disaster of an
interview with axios we've got about a
minute of it right here disagree with
the israelite government policy why not
just stop sales completely well
i disagree with the u.s policy
we couldn't stop selling in the u.s i
think it's fine to
be involved with
a country to be to be a citizen of a
country
and to protest
some of the some of the country's
actions
and
that's essentially
what we're doing in terms of israel we
hugely support israel's right to exist
but we are against a particular policy
you guys are big proponents of voting
rights why do you still sell ice cream
in georgia texas abortion bans
why are you still selling there
i don't know
i mean i mean it's a it's an interesting
question
i don't know what
what that would accomplish
we're working on those issues of voting
rights and
uh
i don't know i you know i mean i think
you ask a really good question and i
think
i'd have to sit down and think about it
for a bit
he'd have to sit down and think about it
for a bit he's half bernie sanders half
larry david we should have put the curb
music in there but it's just such a
perfect such a perfect example about how
these people don't think through
anything and by the way guys you're not
going to believe this those hippies
those peace loving progressive socialist
hippies they sold ben and jerry's about
15 20 years ago for roughly 350 million
dollars to unilever one of the largest
corporations in the entire world uh but
again is is hypocrisy calling it
hypocrisy is not quite enough is it
jesse
no it's not but i they're they're just
par for the course i mean you brought up
that they're huge bernie people and
bernie's a great example of this what do
they have three houses while espousing
all that communist crappy throws out
there but again this is not it's not
hypocrites that's what socialism is
that's what communism is it always works
out that way it's always for the
peasants right it's always for the ones
they should rule over it's never it's
never for them they all want the finer
things in life they just believe they
should rule and deny you the finer
things in life because they are the gods
that'll hand out the economy or hand out
the equality that they believe the world
should do that's that's why the whole
thing has been such a joke it's why it's
rejected all the time it's why it fails
all the time because nobody nobody can
take in that much power and not want
more of it or that much money and not
want more of it it fails all the time
for a reason and those guys are a great
example
sydney this kind of reminded me of the
sanjay gupta joe rogan thing from this
week that when basically these people
who are treated with kid gloves all the
time in media appearances when they have
to do something a little more long form
and i doubt that axios is like the most
difficult place you know that woman
she's perfectly fine obviously but like
i don't think this was like they walked
in thinking this was gonna be the
hardest thing ever that they completely
fold because they really don't know what
they're talking about which is exactly
what happened to sanjay with rogan i
know and it's you know i don't know if
you guys are like me but i get the worst
secondhand embarrassment watching this
stuff because like that pause and he
goes i don't know oh my god i thought my
heart was gonna explode it's so awkward
to listen to but i mean you're right at
the end of the day if you receive no
pushback on anything that you ever say
out in the world or ever put out into
the world as a general rule when you do
come into contact with somebody who
questioned you even and she was being
very nice that interview
she was being very very polite very nice
uh if you're if you still can't answer a
question then it really goes to show
that hey you haven't thought through
your position which i think when it
comes to ice cream people i'm not really
surprised by that in any capacity
because they do slacktivism it's that
thing where oh let's put a colin
kaepernick on a on a ice cream tub and
that's going to be the end of it let's
make our you know millions in sales
we'll manipulate the crap out of the
population then we take our money home
and we sit up on you know in our nice
little house away from all the plebs and
we go hahaha look we did a good thing
for the day so i don't know i mean i'm
not surprised by these people being as
dumb as uh two short planks because
that's kind of what they do but they are
really good at manipulating us i think
that's what's funny about it the people
who buy yours i pity them elijah the
longer i do whatever it is that i do
here the more it's obvious to me that my
old former team pretty much everybody
and there's almost no exclusions to this
it's not necessarily that they're bad
people although there are some bad ones
at the top but pretty much everybody
just does not think about anything they
just think the world exists because it
should exist and it's the way they want
it to be and they have to keep you know
replicating it to be the way they want
it to be but they just don't think about
anything so then you get asked like the
most basic question
and and you completely freeze up
yeah i mean this comes in a world of
view i mean when you think the world's
been around for billions and billions of
years it always was and it always will
be then there's not much incentive to
really think about things it's just to
keep things going and if you think the
world's just a machine and mechanism
with no purpose then you don't need to
have a purpose you just need to react
and so that's where world view largely
comes into how society forms and these
people are just not awake they don't
they don't process information in any
tangible way and dave this makes me miss
i'll tell you this so this is sort of a
white pill for me because
you know this makes me miss the college
wars of like 2016 2017. those are the
good old days oh yeah and you were right
in the thick of that i mean i remember
going to protest i was laughing right
now i was watching some old protest
footage
going out there you know asking people
you know about donald trump and people
telling me donald trump was hitler's
nephew and asking them like i thought
they were joking and then being like no
no i he is and you're like
okay so apparently
being mentally ill is no longer a
disability it's a common trait of our
current society and so i you know i mean
we remember that and these people were
stupid and they've learned to shut up
they've shut up and they've given their
mouthpieces to the forefront they've
become militant because we mocked them
we made fun of them and the sad part is
is they didn't learn
to become smarter they are not trying to
become smarter like jesse said because
they're not hypocrites because they're
dumb the people in power have just
realized that it's not about using these
dumb people at the forefront anymore
they've gone full military industrial
complex communist by using now policy
and using the government to do their
battles for them like the days of the
brown shirts and believing ben and
jerry's is going to accomplish leftist
goals is totally out the window nobody
even relies on these people anymore
because they really don't know what the
hell they're talking about and
unfortunately in some ways they're kind
of victims of their own ignorance